وزاره الدفاع التركيه تنفيذ ضربات جويه
مساء السبت على ما سمته التنظيمات
الارهابيه شمالي سوريا والعراق في اشاره
الى حزب العمال كردستاني وحلفائه واضافته
الوزاره ان العمليه التي سمتها المخلب
السيف تستند الى الماده الحاديه والخمسين
من ميثاق الامم المتحده وتهدف لمنع اي
هجمات ارهابيه واجتثاث الارهاب بحسب
تعبيرها
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم كان ذلك خبر حلقتنا ولنا في
نقاشه 3 مصارعه
[موسيقى]
العمليه العسكريه التركيه ضد حزب العمال
الكردستاني وهلفائه وانت تتجاوز اثار الرد
المحدود على تفجير اسطنبول وكيف ستنعكس
هذه العمليه على المشهد السياسي الداخلي
في تركيا وعلى علاقات انقراض الدول
المتاثره بقصدها معاقل حزب العمال
الكردستاني ثم نبحث في الارتدادات
المحتمله للعمليه المتبادله بين تركيا
وحزب العمال على استقرار المنطقه وما موقف
حلفاء انقره الدوليين من هذه العمليه
[موسيقى]
بعد اسبوع من تفجير في قلب اسطنبول اسقط
قتلى وجرحى ونفذه بحسب انقر حزب العمال
كردستاني اعلنت وزاره الدفاع التركيه ان
مقاتلاتها جنت غارات في ساعه متاخره من
مساء السبت على معاقل ما سمتها التنظيمات
الارهابيه الشماليه سوريا والعراق في
اشاره الى حزب العمال كردستاني وحلفائه
الوزاره التي نشرت المشاهد الاولى للغارات
قالت ان العمليه التي سمتها المخلب السيف
تهدف للقصاصي لما وصفته بالهجوم الغادر في
اشاره الى انفجار اسطنبول الاخيره وبحسب
ما نقله مراسل الجزيره عن مصادر محليه فان
القصف طال ما واقع عسكريه لما تعرف بقوه
سوريا الديمقراطيه في مناطق متفرقه شماليه
سوريا قرب الحدود مع تركيا اما وكاله
رويترز فقد نقلت عن متحدث باسم ما تعرف
بقوه سوريا الديمقراطيه تتشكل وحدات ما يت
الشعب الكرديه عمودها الفقري ان طائره
تركيه قصفت قريتين ماهولتين بالنازحين
بشمال سوريا
[موسيقى]
ليه مناقشه هذا الموضوع معنا من انقر
المحلل السياسي والعسكري نجدت اوزدوجلك
ومن بوسطن الدكتور ماكس
استاذ العلوم
[موسيقى]
السيف هل انتهت بما نفذته هذا اليوم ام
انها مفتوحه
ديس اوبريشن
هذه العمليه
اليها على انها جزء من محاوله التصدي لحزب
العمال الكردستاني ووحدات حمايه الشعب
الكرديه وهي ليست طريقه لي الرد على
البيكاكو وحدات بسبب اخر اعتداء في شارع
الاستقلال نعم هذا الاعتداء اثر على سلطات
التركيه بحيث انه حتى على
البدء بهذا العمليه
من خلال
سكوير
اطلاق نار ليس فقط من خلال الغارات جويه
ولكن ايضا من خلال وسائل مختلفه حتى
من خلال قتال برا وكذلك جوا
الاساس هنا الذي يجب ان ننظر اليه هو
التزامن هذه العملات المختلفه التي غلطت
مناطق في سوريا والعراق في الوقت نفسه اذا
الجبهه التشغيل عن عمليات تمتد على 700
كيلو متر عرضا
ابتويد
فهي 180 كم من الاراضي العراقيه ما يعلمنا
به ذلك هو ان تركيا تنظروا الى مستوى
التهديد على انه نفسه وبالنسبه الى حزب
العمله الكردستاني ووحده حمايه شعب
الكرديه لا تفرق بين
الطرفين
وبتال يتاثر
سؤالي هل نحن امام عمليات جراحيه يقوم بها
الجيش التركي ام انها عمليات قد تتوسع
اكثر
تعتبر
ليست عمليه جراحيه
[موسيقى]
من العمليه التركيه الشامله التي نراها ان
تستمر
التي ننتظرها في سوريا لا نعرف متى ستبدا
ولكن
سوف
يكون من مالاتها التصدي للبيكاكا وواحده
حيوانات شعبي
تفجير اسطنبول كان موقف الرسمي التركي
واضحا من خلال ما قاله وزير الداخليه
التركي في ما يتعلق بما وجهه من رساله
لوشنطر عندما رفض التعزيه وبالتالي باي
مقاربه تتابع واشنطن ما يجري في هذه
المناطق في سوريا في شمال سوريا والعراق
الحقيقه انا اسمي نوع الجواب الذي سمعته
من زميلي انا ارى ما يحصل
ليس على ان هو مختلفا
مختلف عن رايناه ولكنه بمثابه استمراريه
لما بدا في العام 2014 تقريبا
بعد معركه كوباني
همم كوريا
الى
الميليشيات الكرديه في سوريا على انها
الحليف او القوات
الاقرب الى الولايات المتحده من حيث
التصدي لارهاب تنظيم الدوله وهذا مباشره
خلقه مشكله مع تركي لان طبعا نحن نعرف ان
تركيا تنظر الى حزب العمال الكردستاني وكل
الاطراف المرتبطه به على انه التهديد
الاكبر في مجال الارهاب ضدها
الولايات المتحده حنيفه لمواجهه الارهاب
هو يعتبر عدو تركيا
الى العلاقات بين تركيا والولايات المتحده
في مواجهه الارهاب اذا بالنسبه الى
الجنات في اعتداء اسطنبول فبحسب السلطات
التركيه
تم التعرف اليهم على انهم ينتمون الى حزب
العمال الكردستاني وبتحديد شخص هو مواطن
سوري
ارتكب ال او ارتكبت بالاحرى هذا الاعتداء
وذلك
تمثيلا
ميليشات كرديه في سوريا منها وحده حمايه
الشعب الفلسطيني
بطريقه
مختلفه هذه المقاربه الامريكيه فيما يتعلق
بطبيعه الرد التركي على اي عمل هذه
الجغرافيا سواء شمال سوريا او العراق
ما الذي يسمح به الجانب الامريكي ولا يسمح
به في عمليه الضبط الرده التركي
عايز
الوضع معقده
الاسباب اولا السلطات تركيا ومع انها قالت
بثقه عاليه ان الجونات هم من حزب العمال
الكردستاني
البيكاكولا لا يتم تشاركها مع الولايات
المتحده انا لا اعتقد ان الولايات المتحده
لديها مستوى عالم من الثقه
بان حسب العمال كل سنه وهو الذي ارتكب هذا
الاعتدال لانه حصل اعتداءات في تركيا منذ
2016 لم تقتصر على حزب العمال الكردستاني
من حيث ارتكابها ولكن ايضا كانت مستلهمه
من تنظيم الدوله تقول الولايات المتحده لا
تقول ان اردوغان يكتب ولكنها ليست واثقه
فعلا ان الفكره هو الذي يرتكبها ايضا
الولايات المتحده
متحالفه ما عملشات كرديه موجوده في سوريا
ولا سيما الاس دي اف
سبورت عملت الولايات المتحده
ودربت وجهزت هؤلاء المقاتلين الاكراد من
اجل ان يطلعوا بدور اساسي ضد فلول تنظيم
الدوله في سوريا
كذلك تشعر الولايات المتحده بان تدينو
لهؤلاء المقاتلين على الاكرار التيما بعد
معركه كوباني
وبصوره عامه تركيا حليف شمال الاطلس
محبوبون شعبيه جيده في العاصمه واشنطن
يعتبرون
مع هذا الابداع الانزعاج التركي من هذه
المقاربه الامريكيه
ما الذي يضعه الجانب التركي في الحسبان
عندما يقرر الرد على عمليات التجاره
اسطنبول حيل هذه المنظمات تصفها انقر بان
ارهابيه
احب
اعتراض
واليكم السبب في العام 2016 نعم
لم تكن وحده حمايه الشعب الكرديه
الكردستاني
في تركيا
اسمها الدرع الجديد
همم ليس فقط تصديا لوحدات حمايه الشعب
الكرديه ولكن تنظيم الدوله هو الذي كان
الهدف الرئيسي لهذا العمل العمليه اي ان
تركيا كانت اول جهه من الدول على مستوى
الدوله تتخذ اجراءات احاديه ضد تنظيم
الدوله في تلك سنه
وبعد ان ضعف تنظيم الدوله بدانا نرى ان
وحدات حمايه الشعب الكرديه
بصوا ان يتواصل تصبح العدو الاكبر وساره
تتغير
اسماؤه ومنها الاس دي اف قوات سوريا
الديمقراطيه وغيرها وهذا ما اعطته اياها
همم
[موسيقى]
هيئه الاستخباريه والعسكريه الامريكيه في
تلك الفتره
لن نخفف او نقلل من اهميتها العمليه
في استراتيجيه تركيا
ووحدات حمايه الشعب الكرديه هذا عمليه
تصدي ورد ضده هذين
او بالقول لانها عمليات رد على الاعتداء
اسطنبول لا نحن نبسطها بشكل مبالغ به لو
لم تبدا تركيا اي عمليات عابره للحدوث في
سوريا لا راينا المزيد والمزيد من
الاعتداءات من قبل
وحدات حمايه الشعب الكرديه في تركيا
وبالتالي لا يمكن ان نعتبر ان هذين
الطرفين
همم ابرا او اقل ذنبا
تنظيم الدوله
هذه الاطراف لديها نفس استراتيجيه لديها
نفس الاهداف ربما تختلف
ايديولوجياتها ولكن الطريقه المنهجيه هي
نفسها
سيدنا
اراضيها حيث تتواجد هذه
المنظمات هناك شكوى هناك اعتراض من قبل
العراق وتحديد الاقليم كردستان وكذلك هناك
ردود فعل في هذه المناطق هل تضع انقره هذه
الحسابات عندما تنفذ هذه العمليه
بوينتي
السلطات التركيه
المحليه في شمال العراق
والسلطات المركزيه في بغداد اكثر من مره
لاتحادي تدابير واجراءات ملموسه ضد وجود
البيكاكا في شمال العراق
التجاهل الذي
تعتمده كستراتيجيه هذه السلطات المحليه
لانها لم تتحرك ضدها لم تتخذ اي تدابير لم
تتخذ اي اجراءات هي فقط تشتكي بسبب عدم
قدرتها على التحرك ضد
حزب العمال الكردستاني في عدد من المناطق
الجبليه في تلك المنطقه تحاول تركيا ان
تركيا خدمه
ولكن ايضا لحمايه
الحكومه
العراقيه المركزيه وايضا الحكومه في
كردستان
لها اذا كانت تستخدم
في حل لمشكله انعدام السياده في العراق
وفي كردستان العلاقات من دوله الى دوله
موت موت انت تعززه بدلا من ان نرى علاقات
بين دوله من جهه وجهها من غير الدوله من
جهه اخرى هنا بالنسبه الى السلطات
الامريكيه وما ارتكبته من خطا في تعاملها
مع منظمات ارهابيه
وكذلك منظمه ارهابيه هي ايضا تعترف بها
هنا يتحدث زميلي عن ضروره نظر الى قوه
سوريا
ماكس عن هذه الصوره الغير مفهومه
انقر بالنسبه لواشنطنطينيه حاليا
مقيم على اكثر من صعيد وفي نفس الوقت هي
تحمي وتدافع منظمه تصفه انقر بانها
ارهابيه وحتى بعضها مصنف حتى في دول خارج
انقر بانها منظمات ارهابيه وتنفذ عمليات
تقول ان قال بانها هذه المنظمات هي من
تقوم بهذه الاعمال الارهابيه وبالتالي كيف
نفهم هذه المقارنه الامريكيه
ايميلك
اياه تختلف عن المقاربه التركيه الولايات
المتحده توافق تركيا على ان حزب العمال
الكردستاني ومنظمه ارهابيه
هي من خارج الدوله
كيكي تركي
في تركيا
وغيره من المجموعات الكرديه المرتبطه به
في سوريا وفي العراق
بينما ان العاصمه واشنطن لا تكتفي
بالتفرقه بينها بل ايضا تتحالف مع
المقاتلين على اكراد لا صياما في سوريا
على وجه الخصوص من اجل مواجهه او التصدي
لتنظيم الدوله الولايات المتحده لا تريد
ان ترى تركيا
الى طبيعه العلاقه
الموحدده بين مثلا
كردستاني
والقوات سوريا الديمقراطيه او وحدات حمايه
الشعب الكردي على الواي فاي التي تتضمن
الديمقراطيه فهذا موضوع نقاشا وجدان
تركيا
نفسها وانها حتى
قد تشمل النفس الاعضاء نفس العناصر وان
هناك روابط بين هذه الشبكات ولكن بحسب
الفهم الامريكي فان هؤلاء المقاتلين على
اكراد ليس ارهابيين بل يواجهون على
الارهاب ولي هذا نختلف في وجهات النظر انا
وزميلي
ان يستمر على ما هو عليه تنفذ عمليات ترد
تركيا خارج اراضيكا موقف لشركاء دوليه على
سبيل الماده واشنطن مثلا هو على حاله ولكن
لاي مدى يمكن ضمان الوضع على هذه الحاله
والا ينزلق الى ما هو اخطر من الوضع
الحالي
ياه دي دي بورش كيس سنريوس
التصدي لحزب الاتحاد
يريد رؤيه هذه
المواجهه اذا كان هذا الحزب غير مرتبط
بحسب العمال الكردستاني ولكن التفرقه هنا
غير ممكنه
حزب الاتحاد
بفضل دعم الولايات المتحده وربما حتى
حلفاء اخرين لتركيا داخل شمال الاطلسي ولا
شك في ان تركيا سوف تتحرك من اجل تفكيك
هذا الحزب الان
لتر 4 فورس
بمثابه قوتنا عسكريه
مركبه يمكنها ان تستخدمه انظمه اسلحه حصلت
عليها من الولايات المتحده وان تقوم بعد
الاعتداء داخل الاراضي تركيا
الى الامن القوميه التركي هنا يطرح السؤال
ليس هناك فرق بين العلاقه
بين القاعده
وتنظيم الدوله وبين حزب العمال وحزب
الاتحاد
العلوم السياسيه في جامعه النور
الى هنا تنتهي هذه الحلقه من برنامج ما
وراء الخبر الى اللقاء
[موسيقى]